ce soir michel j'aimerais revoir enfin
bon interview vivement dimanche et on y
va il faut le chien
bonjour un vivement dimanche
exceptionnel je reçois la référence
s'étire ardisson d'ailleurs on le voit
tout de suite puisque publica et plus
jeunes de 40 ans est à + tva il a alors
thierry
vous en avez rêvé nous aussi la france
entière attend ce moment vous êtes une
idole vous êtes la référence le roi de
la pub de là près de l'édition comment
vous avez réussi tout ça parce que déjà
je suis assez exceptionnel oui on peut
le dire j'ai quelque chose que les gens
n'ont pas c'est vrai tout ça je me fais
sans bosser sans bosser je passe mes
nuits à prendre de la coke avec des
mannequins dans des boîtes dans mes
boîtes de partout
pour la première fois en 17 ans le
public de vivement dimanche se découvre
un mot qu'il connaissait pas par tous
par tous voilà qu'est ce que t'es fier
d'être considéré comme le meilleur coup
de paris écoutent oui parce que je pense
qu'à 66 bientôt 67 tu les fais pas tu
fais 24 et demi
le plaisir que je donne à ma femme est
absolument incroyable et elle est très
attaché à moi alors c'est quoi une bonne
interwiew pour toi tu irais est-ce que
j'ai une bonne interview doit se
terminer deux temps en temps pas est-ce
que sucer c'est tromper toujours
toujours
[Applaudissements]
du film a gardé un goût tout le monde en
parle s'arrête la france est en larmes
les rues sont désertes
il ya des foules immenses
de votre domicile arnoux qui supplie le
retour de tout le monde il ya un mec qui
s'est immolé par le feu devant france
télévisions
qui quitte france 2 ouais tu arrives à
canal tu retrouves ta liberté de ton tu
retrouves la cam tu retrouves l'epu tout
ce que tu as dit que c'est vrai que
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles à
l'époque j'ai choisi canal sauf que
quand je suis arrivé sur canal c'était
fini et là tu découvres ce que j'ai
découvert le premier la verveine voilà
tu te tu te couches tôt voilà tu
commences à faire du sport oui ça se
voit oui tu commences à tabliers toutes
les couleurs oui ça se voit ce mois
d'août vient ce magnétisme avec les
femmes
écoute c'est tu l'attendais pas celle là
non
[Applaudissements]
d'où tu viens
bien qu'en fait
je connais bien les femmes puisque j'en
ai été une moi même bien sûr et donc je
sais les séduire en devenant une femme
sinon qu'elles ont l'impression d'avoir
quelqu'un comme elle et ça marche très
bien qu'est ce qui te manque toi qui a
tout réussi coucher avec toi
[Applaudissements]
j'ai tout lu sauf ça
ce ton lit mans dimanche se termine
c'est génial sur merci n'annoncez pas
fils étaient remerciés ta femme audrey
oui ton producteur stéphane si bien sûr
jacques sanchez oui ma femme ma chienne
mes copains et techniciens didier frau
lille réalisateur biens services et les
longues la semaine prochaine à ta place
chez là avec une question est ce qu'elle
est morte
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus